أنا لست هنا لبدء نوع من الاحتجاج
ومن الناحية السياسية، هذا ليس من شأننا أيضًا، لكننا كذلك
في الميدان نرى الأمور مباشرة
وما يقال هنا في الاستديوهات وما يقال
المستوى السياسي ببساطة لا يتوافق مع الواقع وإذا
ونستمر كما نحن حاليا
احنا في طريق انتحاري يا ريت اللي قاعد
هنا والذين يجلسون في المنزل ويشاهدون يفهمون أننا كذلك
في حرب وجود وإذا لم تغير دولة إسرائيل
سياستها اللحاق بالركب تكون متساهلة وتكون
أكثر شجاعة واتخاذ قرارات شجاعة وليس
كرر الأشياء التي جربناها من قبل ولم تنجح
نحن في طريقنا إلى فشل ذريع، وهذا أيضًا يوم السبت
المختطفين، ولكنه أيضًا استعادة الأمن، على ما أقترح
لمن يعتقد أن الظل يعمل بشكل جيد
اسأل الجنود من فضلك إذا كنت على ما أنت عليه
أعني أننا لا نبذل جهدًا أكبر، ولا ندخل
إنهم لا ينهون لحم الخنزير بالطريقة التي تريد رؤيتها، لا
انهيارها لا يعيد المختطفين، فماذا؟
انظر، أنا جالس هنا وكنت نائماً لمدة أسبوع
ومن بين احتياطياتنا في القدس كأنها استمرار
احتياطي الخاص بي لأنني أعتقد من كل قلبي أن هناك
لقد تبعتنا قوة جبارة، لقد جئت من المنطقة، أسمع
القوات والعديد من الناس يأتون إلينا
الكلمات والتحدث بنفس الأصوات التي أعرفها موجودة
لدينا قوة هائلة للتأثير عليك والضغط عليك
يجب على الحكومة أن تتصرف بطرق تؤدي إلى إحباط الناس حقًا
الواقع سوف يتركك يا عزيزي
اذهب بيبي، أنا أقول لك، لقد كبرت
الصهيونية في بيت باب ليشام ابنه من ابنه ليخ
ذكرنا رئيس الوزراء بأن LED فصل
لقد قتلنا
ليس لدينا الطفل
قوه
لقد صنع أنوب الوضع الاجتماعي في إسرائيل
هو يار هو ميم ابنه هو
يا بني، لقد انفصلنا منذ 42 عامًا، وقد أصبحنا بالفعل في العشرين من عمرنا
شانا أقول لا يوجد شيء، لا يوجد شيء، يا أطفالي
Ledo إلى sm ولكن الآن أو ذلك يصدر إشارة
مجنون أو إشارة حياكة
عدد أكبر بكثير من الطلاب في المدينة د في تل أبيب
الخلفية أن مدير المدرسة أ. هيلون تم غسله
المشاركات التي تحدثت عن الحاجة إلى فهم الحاجة
ولإظهار المعاناة في غزة أيضًا، استمعوا إليها
أعدها إلى مكانها وانظر ماذا حدث بالأمس
عندما تعود إلى منصبها يكون ذلك بمثابة مظاهرة من قبل الطلاب
ضد مدير بلديات ياد تل أبيب
يقول رافيف شيئًا مهمًا جدًا بالنسبة لي أيضًا
يجب أن تكون المدارس والأكاديمية أيضًا مكانًا
حيث يتم تطوير الناس وتشجيعهم على مجموعة متنوعة من الآباء بعد ذلك
هذه هي القصة بالضبط، هذه هي القصة بالضبط، هذا هو الأمر
أننا مدينون اليوم في الجامعة هناك صمت
بسبب الخوف تمامًا، هذا بالطبع يتعلق بما حدث
في جامعة تل أبيب لم تكن تستخدم الرموز
المتعلقة بالحرب لماذا يجب أن يكون هذا المكان
حيثما تثار الآراء، يتم تعليم الناس التعبير عن آرائهم
البعض الآخر مدعوم بحقائق مسببة غير هجومية
لماذا تفعل هذا الشيء، لماذا القضاء على الأدغال
بالضبط حيث ينبغي أن يحدث أو